First question. After a recent cheap swan test,
you suggested two tablespoons per day at the final nine five one.
Since I can't afford $55 a week for one supplement,
because that supplement is about $55.
And two tablespoons will probably be consumed in about a week.
Should I just skip it or do whatever I can afford?
It was a good question for everybody. Like, what if I can't afford
to continue at the dosage that you asked me to continue at?
What should I do? Well, there's really two ways to do it.
You could drop down into a smaller dose per day.
Or you could take the recommended just a couple days a week.
So if you could afford my dollars a month for that supplement,
by taking it maybe two days a week, maybe take it on Sunday,
that's one way to do it. So you're getting a higher dose that's affected,
affecting the tissue over those two days.
That's one way to take it. So it depends on the supplement.
Now, Thailand diet pack, what is the supplement to help this lodge?
Bad estrogens from the estrogens receptor on the cancer cell,
itself cancer membrane, cell membrane.
So in this case, I would suggest you take a lower dosage per day.
So with this supplement, it'd be better to have a lower dosage per day,
so you have some residual dosage in your tissues on a daily basis.
But other supplements, it may be better to
that did create a video on pulsing supplements.
But in this case, I'd say lower dose per day would be better.